veteran NASA astronaut scott kelly
embarked on a historic mission in 2015
ramping up and liftoff the year in space
starts now Kelly Kornienko padalka on
their way towards the international
space station scott kelly blasted into
orbit to begin his record-setting
340 day mission to help study the
effects of long-term spaceflight on the
human body Kelly worked on more than 400
scientific studies during his time on
the International Space Station he
conducted three spacewalks before
returning to Earth in March 2016 Kelly
has since retired as an astronaut his
new book endurance a year in space a
lifetime of discovery reflects on his
time with NASA and his famous mission
Scott Kelly good morning good morning
talk about what has been the most
significant impact on you well on me
personally I think it's more of an
impact on just how this overall
experience has has changed me and I
think for the better when we spend time
away from Earth and have this you know
orbital perspective I think it makes us
more empathetic why is it about how we
fit into a larger picture exactly
exactly it was a real privilege to do
this and have this experience you come
back shorter you know I stretched I
stretched a little bit yeah but then I
immediately shrunk that back down my
brother pointed that out to me back to
normal competition between you had
normal normal six foot six explain that
because part of the thing they measure
too is your telomeres which actually
elongated which they say our scientists
say can be a sign of lung longevity
you've told me that they kind of shrunk
back what does that tell us about the
science of of the human body about
longevity all those things you know that
was an interesting experiment a genetic
experiment because the the hypothesis
was me being in space the radiation the
you know challenging living and working
environment would affect my telomeres
which is an indication of our physical
age in a negative way and when when the
results are the exact opposite of what
you expect it's a really interesting
experiment and now I don't think it
means that space is going to be a
Fountain of Youth
but there's definitely more to
investigate there but is because of
gravity is because of radiation is
because of might just be the clean
living thinking of moralistic face what
were you most excited about to have when
you came home oh you know being around
people that I care about and love the
weather hamburgers that stayed on the
plate as opposed to funny you know
floating is makes most things
challenging but I think you know in
space we don't have a lot of fresh like
fruits and vegetables so people crave
that kind of thing what would you write
in the book when you first arrived on
the space station for nearly a year-long
mission you write quote it occurs to me
for a moment that this might be one of
the stupider things I've ever done how
talk about the apprehension well I've
been there for a hundred and fifty nine
days just four years previously so when
I got on board the place you know looks
the same smells the same sounded the
same and this is day one and I'm
thinking the monotony of space which was
harder though the psychological or the
physiological absolutely the
psychological part of it you know just
being isolated being separated from my
family my big concern was always not for
my own physical safety but something
happening to someone I care about on the
ground which I experienced on my
previous mission when my sister-in-law
congresswoman Giffords was shot is is
NASA back in a sense we had this thing
about trying to develop supersonic speed
plane they can fly at supersonic speed
without the kind of noise they talk
about landing on moon in 2030 they can
do that mm-hmm you believe they can do
that oh absolutely absolutely believe
that we have you know the humming Mars
not the moon yeah Mars yeah without a
doubt and coming back to yeah absolutely
you know like I'll steal something my
brother often says he says it's not
about going to Mars is not about rocket
science it's about political science
which is getting the wheel took send the
money to go there absolutely yes you
trained with the Russian space program
as well as the u.s. space program what
what are the differences between the two
there's a lot you know but they've been
great colleagues they
actually have to do a lot with less
funding they don't have the same you
know source of funding that we do in our
space program but they've been great
partners you know that that's what makes
space and the space station so great one
of the things is that it's this
international partnership where
countries that are formally and
sometimes at odds with each other
enemies can work together on something
collaborative that benefits us all do
you assume you've been in space for the
last time I hope not but likely you know
unless we get a pretty good stream of
commercial flights going like we may
have from not from NASA but from private
yeah absolutely and that's where if I
ever flew again we'll be there yeah you
said that it gave you a different
feeling about how we a small part of a
larger than universe I mean how does
that a picture everyday life I think it
makes you more of an environmentalist
looking at the planet I think it makes
you more of a you know a kind of a
humanist you know looking out at seven
and a half billion people on earth no
political borders and then just hearing
all the news that you know happens on
this planet on a daily basis mostly bad
news talking to the choir here it really
changes you and make you yeah makes you
more empathetic so we should send all
world leaders up to space yeah we need
those lessons back here on earth
interestingly enough Misha my Russian
colleague says if we want to solve
problems between Russia and the United
States we should just send our two
presidents to space for a year he's
gonna get in trouble now from you didn't
say was a bad idea though Kelly thank
you for your time and welcome back on
terra firma thank you
endurance goes on sale tomorrow